[Musique]
je suis ici pour vous faire une
formidable révélation la photo que vous
allez voir dans quelques instants
fa sans doute changé votre vision du
monde durablement
alors franchement regardez bien votre
souffle voilà c'est ça ma révélation
mesdames et messieurs les bisounours
existe je les ai rencontrés la photo en
témoigne c'est ma vie de faire des
rencontres dans des peuples lointains de
voyager notamment à travers les
émissions de découverte que j'anime et
je dois reconnaître que cette rencontre
là en particulier elle a vraiment
apporté quelque chose de très fort à mon
existence
bon alors je vous rassure je ne suis pas
fou et je ne suis pas assez sous drogue
pour voir des ours en peluche vivant
évidemment cette photo c'est juste une
petite blague pour rendre hommage à des
gens qui m'inspirent beaucoup ce que
péjorativement on appelle les bisounours
vous savez ce sont tous ces gens qui ont
une vision du monde fraternel et je
crois que si on les écoutait plus eh
bien on vivrait mieux collectivement
tout simplement
alors si je suis là c'est pour être leur
porte-parole
c'est quoi un bisounours eh bien
figurez-vous qu'en préparant cette aide
je me suis rendu compte que ce mot avait
sa définition dans le dictionnaire en
substance ce qu'il nous dit c'est que ce
sont des gens d'une extraordinaire
beauté et d'un optimisme béat qui vivent
dans un décalage profond avec la réalité
extrême bonté optimisme béat et décalage
profond avec la réalité
et quand on passe de la fiction au monde
réel justement j'ai constaté que ce
terme était de plus en plus utilisé pour
discréditer des gens qui ont une vision
nuancée modérée de la société à un
moment où je pense que vous l'aurez
constaté aussi on est de plus en plus
poussés à être dans le pour ou le contre
et où il semble que de plus en plus de
gens est envie d'en découdre
j'ai sûr que vous la connaissez tous
cette expression ça va on n'est pas dans
le monde des bisounours
je pense qu'on l'entend à peu près de
150 fois par jour sur les plateaux des
chaînes d'information continue pendant
250 fois c'est pas très nuancée ça doit
être un peu moins mais quand même
par des polémistes qui veulent ainsi
renvoyé dans les cordes un contradicteur
qui viendraient modéré une dans leur
indignation grossière c'est aussi une
expression qui est très utilisé par des
responsables politiques pour pouvoir
montrer le manque de lien avec le vrai
monde avec la vraie vie avec les vrais
gens d'une personne qui n'est pas
d'accord avec eux je suis sûr que vous
l'avez senti en tout cas que vous l'avez
entendu cette expression notamment dans
des débats récurrents comme ceux sur la
sécurité dans nos villes dans nos rues
il y aurait d'un côté le camp des
réalistes autoproclamé ceux qui pensent
que tout va mal et que nous sommes au
bord du chaos
et puis de l'autre côté pour ne même pas
parler des laxistes les bisounours c'est
à dire les gens qui comme moi pensent
que oui on peut s'émouvoir des problèmes
d'insécurité déploré mêmes s'indigner de
la mort d'adolescents dans des rixes
entre bandes rivales n'est que non nous
ne sommes pas au bord de la guerre
civile
personnellement ma vie de voyageur m'a
amené dans des pays en guerre civile ou
au bord de la guerre civile
et je peux vous garantir que nous en
sommes très loin
alors évidemment quand je vous dis tout
ça je pense que la nuance et la
modération ont un peu de mal à s'imposer
aujourd'hui parce qu'elles ne sont pas
forcément très adapté aux grandes
problématiques qui traversent notre
époque
par exemple l'épidémie de coronavirus ou
encore le terrorisme
je crois que toutes ces questions
mettent vraiment en doute notre capacité
à garder notre sang froid et à ne pas
vouloir désigner un ennemi ou un groupe
d'ennemis qu'on pourrait montrer du
doigt et sur lequel on pourrait déverser
toute notre colère notre haine ou nos
frustrations ou aussi j'ai cette
tentation des fois et puis lorsque
l'émotion la colère et la haine sont
remplacés par la réflexion on se rend
compte que les situations sont bien plus
complexes et d'ailleurs c'est ça qui est
difficile
il n'y a pas une solution toute faite à
la plupart des grandes questions qui
traversent notre époque
le problème le second problème c'est que
la complexité et la nuance est bien ça
se marie très mal avec 2 140 caractères
sur twitter
et avec cette façon de communiquer des
réseaux sociaux ou les débats deviennent
des invectives et où les questions
complexes deviennent des débats
simpliste par exemple je vous pose la
question êtes vous pour ou contre le
mouvement des gilet jaune
etes-vous pour ou contre les vaccins en
général et tout pour contre la manière
dont vos gouvernements gèrent la
pandémie de covile 19 oui ou non les
policiers sont ils tous violents
oui ou non les boomers vous savez cet
horrible expression ok boomers c'est à
dire ces gens nés dans les trente
glorieuses ont-ils vraiment détruit
notre planète en se fichant des
générations futures ou a contrario oui
ou non les jeunes sont ils tous
d'affreux glandeurs lobotomisés par leur
smartphone et que dire des questions sur
la laïcité
les caricatures du prophète mahomet ou
encore sur les discriminations liées au
genre ou à la couleur de peau très
sincèrement si vous avez un avis tranché
pour contre sur toutes ces questions
honnêtement je vous admire ou en fait
vous me fait un petit peu peur aussi
parce que - pour rien vous cacher je
passe pas des moments très drôles depuis
quelques années dans les discussions où
l'on envoie des certitudes dans la
figure et où je me sens un peu petit
garçon pour ne pas dire bisounours avec
mes positions nuancées
ouais alors écoute je crois que c'est
pas exactement ça tu vois oui je suis
d'accord mais en même temps et là je me
faire ratatiner par les personnes qui
ont des convictions très fortes et
pourtant j'ai compris récemment que la
conviction très forte la conviction la
plus forte que je pouvais avoir c'était
celle de la nuance oui la nuance est une
conviction et je m'en suis rendu compte
en repensant à l'expérience la plus
marquante la plus profonde de mon
enfance celle qui m'a le plus cimenter
le plus façonné c'est d'avoir grandi au
milieu d'êtres humains d'adultes qui
avait le courage de la nuance qui ont
choisi cette voie et qui m'ont permis
d'être là puisqu'ils ont accompagné un
amour qui franchement avait bien des
obstacles devant lui ils lui ont permis
de s'épanouir c'est l'amour de mes
parents alors dans cette histoire il ya
deux femmes qui ont joué un rôle majeur
je vous disais tout à l'heure un
bisounours et optimisme béat excessive
bonté et décalage avec la réalité est
bien ces deux femmes je peux vous dire
qu'on était loin de la définition du
bisounours alors celle qui le plus à
droite
elle s'appelle fatima dit les lacets ma
grand mère algérienne
et puis à côté d'elle en noir et blanc
voilà lucienne ma grand mère française
qui était en fait la mère de ma maman
est donc ces deux femmes l on tue un
destin absolument extraordinaire ce sont
des pages d'histoire du 20e siècle
fatima elle est née au début donc du 20e
à une date que nous ne connaissons pas
dans un pays colonisé l'algérie elle a
connu la guerre d'indépendance de son
pays qu'il a touché jusque dans sa chair
puisque mon grand père est mort il a été
tué pendant cette guerre
ensuite elle a élevé seul ses neuf
enfants jusqu'à mourir à la fin des
années 90 dans la décennie noire
algérienne lorsque le terrorisme a tué
des dizaines de milliers de gens dans ce
pays
ce dont je me souviens et j'adore cette
photo n'a grand mère c'est qu'elle nous
regardaient toujours droit dans les yeux
et que la moindre de ses décisions avait
dix fois plus de valeur qu'une
résolution de l'onu pour nous quoi elle
avait une espèce d'autorité naturelle
qui faisait qu'on était tous un peu
comme ça à se taire et à se tourner les
pouces quand elle nous parlait mais
au-delà de ça c'était une grand mère
très aimante très drôle très joyeuse et
puis je la revois aussi faire sa prière
dont l'appartement d'alger ou d'oran à
l'appel du muezzin
lorsqu'on partait en vacances dans ma
famille algérienne lucienne elle est
bien il vient d'un monde complètement
opposées là encore une tranche de vie
incroyable
né en 1922 mortes en 2009 87 ans d'une
vie commencée après la première guerre
mondiale dans la france rurale dont tant
d'hommes étaient morts dans les
tranchées de verdun
elle a connu la mécanisation des
campagnes la deuxième guerre mondiale le
droit de vote des femmes
l'émergence de l'informatique et même
des réseaux sociaux à la fin de sa vie
et alors quand je repense à ma grand
mère eh bien je revois d'abord ses mains
de travailleuses de la terre des mains
abîmées par ce travail mais qui
racontait bien sa vie et puis je la
revois aussi dans son jardin au milieu
de ces arbres fruitiers de ces légumes
ou nous ont joué et des moments qu'on
passait quand on allait à la messe de
minuit avec elle et mon grand-père les
soirs de noël dans la petite église du
village enneigé de haute savoie où il
vivait donc vous l'aurez compris ce sont
deux femmes qui n'auraient jamais dû se
rencontrer mais c'était sans compter sur
deux trublions qui était tout simplement
mes parents et qui s'appelle mohamed et
bernadette
alors des fois je vous fais une
confidence on s'est quand même demander
souvent avec ma soeur s'ils s'étaient
pas mis ensemble juste pour le fun parce
que franchement mohamed et bernadette
fallait le faire
bravo à eux c'est un peu couscous aux
lardons ou les pièces de boulevard
parisienne mais en tout cas eux aussi
leur vie c'est quand même vraiment une
tranche de notre histoire
ils se sont rencontrés dans les années
70 sur les rives du lac d'annecy est là
et bien évidemment l'histoire d'un
couple mixte
à cette époque n'allait pas forcément de
soi de nombreux obstacles se mettait
face à eux
mon père par exemple devait trouver sa
place dans le milieu rural
d'où venaient ma mère alors moi j'ai
souvent jugés avec beaucoup de dureté
cette époque j'en ai voulu un peu aux
gens qui les ont regardés de travers
mais mes parents eux c'est étonnant mais
ils l'ont vécu cette époque ils font
preuve de beaucoup plus de nuances donc
j'ai essayé de raconter cette histoire à
leur manière pour eux s'il y avait des
obstacles
c'est aussi qu'on était dans un moment
où la diversité de la société française
la diversité des religions la diversité
des couleurs de peau des cultures
n'était pas aussi apparente
et puis ils me disent toujours que
l'ouverture sur le monde n'était
évidemment pas aussi grande que celle
que nous vivons aujourd'hui est donc
c'était très difficile pour eux
d'imaginer pouvoir vivre les choses
simplement avec des gens qui avaient du
mal à anticiper ce que pouvait être une
culture étrangère
et n'oublions pas aussi que cette
histoire elle prend vie quelques années
seulement après la guerre d'algérie et
les guerres de décolonisation qui avait
laissé des traces profondes dans la
société française mais dans ma famille
dans mes familles un miracle a eu lieu
plutôt que de se tourner le dos ma
famille algérienne et ma famille
française ont décidé de se rapprocher
alors comment est ce qui s'est fait ces
miracles et d'un d'abord il s'est fait
avec beaucoup de courage ce fameux
courage de la nuance un jour mes grands
parents maternels ont décidé qu'ils
accepteraient mon père tel qu'il était
non pas tel qu'il aurait aimé qu'il soit
il on le décide et que cet amour
pourrait s'épanouir tels que mes parents
l'avaient décidé ça c'est du courage
l'union de la famille en dépendait et
ils l'ont fait passer avant toute
considération est derrière ce courage je
pense qu'il y avait beaucoup d'amour
aussi et puis une fois que le courage
est arrivé hier cette magie
ce processus cette alchimie
extraordinaire qu'on appelle la
rencontre ont cessé ce moment où des
personnes qui n'ont rien à voir se
retrouvent et où tout d'un coup elle
arrive à voir qu'elles ont un terrain
d'entente à partir duquel elles peuvent
discuter ensemble partager ensemble
jusqu à s'aimer et même devenir amis
alors dans mes souvenirs d'enfant ces
moments là ça passe par des choses
toutes simples mais essentielles par
exemple des repas de famille dans la
cours de mes grands parents dans leur
ferme en france ma grand mère fatima
arrivait dans la tenue que vous avez
vues sur la photo elle s'asseyait elle
mangeait l hôtel à la fin du repas nous
pour moins que ça on aurait dû retourner
dans nos champs mais elle avait le droit
de le faire et puis je me souviens qu
autour de la table il y avait des habits
différent il y avait des accents
différents
il y avait une façon de parler français
différentes il fallait parfois que mon
père traduisent à ma grand mère pour
qu'elle comprenne ce qui se passait mais
il y avait des échanges
il y avait de la convivialité des rires
et des instants tout simple qui
permettait de comprendre aussi qu'on
avait des valeurs communes
je revois aussi mon père et mon grand
père qui travaillait ensemble alors mon
père c'était li dan du bricolage il
travaillait dans le bâtiment et mon
grand-père lui on va dire qu'il jouait
plutôt en ligue 2 pour tout ce qui était
bricolage je crois que j'ai beaucoup à
l'été lui et je les revois tous les deux
sur le toit de la maison de mon grand
père en train de réparer des choses de
se passer des outils de se donner des
conseils
bref de collaborer d'être dans la
collaboration
et tout ça ça se termine évidemment
autour d'un bon café où la discussion
continuer et on apprenait à devenir des
amis très fort puisque je crois que mon
père et mon grand-père sont peut-être
les deux meilleures amies j'ai pu voir
dans ma vie alors aujourd'hui mais
quatre grands parents sont morts et
j'espère qu'ils continuent ce dialogue
là haut parce que il croyait en des
lieux différents
mais en un même paradis donc j'espère
pour eux qu'ils sont sont retrouvés là
haut et je souhaite surtout à tous les
enfants du monde de vivre une expérience
comme celle ci parce qu'elle vous donne
une espèce de confiance dans la vie une
espèce de vision des adultes
extraordinaire parce que vous les voyez
se hisser vous les voyez se grandir
aller au delà des eaux
ce tacle faire preuve de réflexion faire
preuve de courage faire preuve de nuance
et à travers cela faire preuve de paix
et pour tout vous dire j'ai eu
l'impression à mon humble niveau je peux
pas comparer l'histoire la petite
histoire de ma famille à la grande
histoire du monde à mon humble niveau de
vivre un peu ce que ces deux hommes ont
vécu nelson mandela et frederik de klerk
les artisans de la fin de l'apartheid au
début des années 90 en afrique du sud ce
système de ségrégation qui rendait les
populations non blanches inférieur quand
je lis les récits de mandela notamment
il raconte que ce processus s'est passé
un peu de la même manière avec le choix
que ce système devait se terminer et
deux hommes qui étaient deux leaders qui
avaient fait le même choix et puis à
partir de là avec une nécessité une
volonté de faire preuve de nuance
qu'elle est l'ancrage historique
sociologique culturelle religieux de
l'autre pour essayer de mieux le
comprendre et à partir de là
ces deux hommes ont réussi l'exploit
formidable de sortir de l'apartheid sans
bain de sang tout simplement en faisant
en sorte de dialoguer les gens et de
créer une forme de réconciliation
la nuance force à dire que tout n'est
pas réglé en afrique du sud mandela mais
au moins ils sont réussis cela et c'est
ce qui leur avait qu'une valu d'ailleurs
le prix nobel de la paix alors moi pour
paraphraser un peu de manière balourde
un grand discours de pêche fais un rêve
aujourd'hui et j'espère que vous le
ferez avec moi je fais le rêve que
l'armée des bisounours maintenant se
lève
l'armée de tous ces gens qui croient
franchement sincèrement sans avoir peur
de le penser et passer pour des gens
niais et mièvre qu'on peut vivre
ensemble qu'il est possible d'avoir des
positions nuancées et modérée et qu'on a
tous à y gagner
je souhaite que cette armée elle se lève
et qu'à ce moment là vous savez on
traîne des grands drapeaux en mettant
des bisounours dessus et puis que quand
vous vous investirez pleinement dans les
débats sur les réseaux sociaux
parce que l'armée elle doit se lever là
aussi eh bien vous utilisiez le hashtag
bisounours power tout simplement pour
dire avec vos drapeaux et vos hashtag
que vous êtes peut-être une armée mais
avant tout que vous êtes des soldats de
la paix
merci beaucoup
[Musique]